you know i'm just checking my watch now
it seems it's time for the scene and
unseen segment where we explore the
cultural stories of the day i usually
watch this from my house now i'll get to
live it we turn now to fox news
contributor extraordinaire raymond
arroyo ray i'm also going to catch up
with you this weekend on my show one
nation but legendary tv producer norman
lear in a new york times op-ed i saw
this uh cites his landmark show all in
the family he claims get this that
archie bunker would have voted for trump
but also would have abandoned trump
after january 6th actor rob reiner
meathead continued the theme
i do think that archie would have been
uh
really upset to see
cops beaten by
insurgents and then to find out as time
goes by that trump was the uh
was at the hub of all this and and was
trump's uh operation all together i
think he would have
gone the way of of liz cheney and adam
kinzinger
brian as archie might have said to
reiner meathead go stifle yourself
rob reiner is a great director but come
on archie is a fictional character brian
i'm kind of disturbed that we have
reached a point where these creatives
are now turning these beloved sitcom
characters into political avatars i mean
this is like somebody suggesting that
the golden girls would be supporting
desantis because he kept their bingo
game rolling through the pandemic or
that george and wheezy jefferson changed
their party affiliation because of the
violence in new york city or maybe they
would say there's a split in the munster
family herman and lily are attending a
trump rally but grandpa's volunteering
in cheyenne for liz cheney's re-election
campaign all of this is nonsense these
are fictional characters they're beloved
and they shouldn't be toyed with in this
way brian you know i interviewed carol
o'connor i did my last his last
interview almost my last but his last
interview and uh he often talked about
the tensions with norman lear over this
character and even though carol o'connor
was a liberal politically and personally
he had such respect for this character
and who he was representing this part of
america that maybe was caricatured in
one way they would often fight with lear
over the direction of the scripts and
the character others should follow that
lead
but you remember you know what you made
me think of raymond as you went through
all these great shows they were
unbelievable sitcoms then families got
together and discussed and watched right
and they were part of the fabric i think
we're so diffused now with streaming and
all the cable channels i don't see that
ever happening again do you ever see us
in the scene well they brought us
together brian
they brought generations together and
you know look i'm all if people want to
have a political viewpoint fine uh have
a fundraiser donate raise your voice but
to take beloved creations like this and
turn it against part of the populace i
just think it's off limits i think it's
it's bad form
right and ray just hands off happy days
that's where the rubber hits the road
for me yeah don't do it meanwhile i need
your reaction to this beyonce made
headlines today she's promising to
remove an offensive word from her new
song called heated ray
yeah well i'll let the audience pick the
offensive part of this lyric i dare you
listen
drinking my water
tuesday
now brian beyonce uses the n word filthy
terms for male female genitalia breasts
and
ass but
spazz is the offensive term in that
lyric uh apparently some in the disabled
community have raised concerns about
this they say spaz is uh it diminishes
those who might have can't control their
muscles so
beyonce is removing the word spazz never
mind that it continues on that backside
that's perfectly fine
i don't think she went far enough with
the cleanup and the lyric revision i
mean lerner and lotion i can tell you
raymie do you like when you get a little
bit older sometimes you mellow i mean
she's a parent you know you would think
we haven't really seen her in a while
uh barely dressed dancing around and now
she comes back more vile than ever
putting out x-ray x-rated lyrics plus
what about the dimpled ass community
what about them are they insulted by
being used in her songs have you thought
about that
right or those with stretch mark breasts
apparently i won't recreate the words
she uses in her delightful lyric written
by drake uh uh
incidentally he wrote those lovely
lyrics but why you would sing them as a
renowned woman who young people look to
i don't quite get that
right and they were wonderfully put
together the great poetry there i think
it'll go down in history
a few weeks ago
lizzy a few weeks ago removed the same
lyric from her song
girls no i oh
hold my bed
do you see this
you see i i mean i i understand how
people get insulted by by these terms
but the question is intentionality brian
whether they were intentionally making
fun of a community with the word in that
context she really isn't but she too
decided to remove that word while
teaching young girls of america it's
perfectly fine to refer to young women
other young women
with the b word i won't repeat it rhymes
with which but i just don't know why
this coarsening of language and and
trash talk
is acceptable and yet we find this tiny
little word that only offends people if
you're really looking for it and that's
the one we take out makes no sense to me
right you know this is so funny in
preparing for this segment i've never
seen more dashes and exclamation and
different types of
symbols from a keyboard it's almost like
the wheel of fortune in the beginning of
a puzzle i don't even know the intention
we could only get one or two letters
before we offended somebody at the fcc
but we'll move on forward
shows like the 25
in my life so i could understand what
they're trying to sing about meanwhile
research shows that 25 percent of
millennials are now living with their
parents that's up nine percent for 1971.
yeah well that was back when meathead
was living with archie bunker brian but
now a sarah lawrence professor is
suggesting this could be good for
america he writes there's a possible
silver lining to these newly
reconstituted multi-generational
households they may help us improve our
democracy sharing spaces with family
members may also compel more political
participation and improve our loneliness
epidemic among young americans now brian
one would think if if a 30 year old is
still living with mom and dad and not by
their choice
hopefully the lesson would be we need
better opportunities so we can all live
independently and grow as individual
people that should be the first lesson
and and i'm not opposed to them living
together that's a good thing when
generations are together my question is
when you have an economy thrusting this
on young people it stunts their
development and their independence
that's never good
yeah
hey greg hey great grandma pass the
sweet and low is not something i thought
i'd be saying uh but i also would i also
would say this the iroquois who are very
family oriented all lived in one long
house and they seem to have done fine
right in the state i'm from new york so
maybe we can learn from the l.a times
after all raymond i got some bad news
yes
i just checked my watch we're out of
time
oh
well i'm gonna have to go back and watch
the all i have to go watch all in the
family reruns so right on time i'll see
you this weekend i hope you could find
it okay
all right all right thanks so much
raymond arroyo it's always great hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else